BEN FRIED: Are we ready?
OK, let's get started.
The Wave for this event is at
http://bit.ly/appengine2 and
the moderator gadget inside the
Wave is a great place for you
to post questions as
they come to you.
We'll make sure we visit the
moderator at the end of the
session and answer all the
questions that are there, so
please take advantage of it.
Excuse me.
We did this crazy thing.
We took a whole bunch of
corporate applications, the
kind of things an enterprise
would never think about running
anywhere except in their own
data center, and we wrote them
and run them on AppEngine.
We're here today to tell
you how we did it, so
you can do it too.
I'm Ben, Ben Fried.
I'm Google's CIO.
I'm here with Justin, Matt,
and Irwin, and we're going to
talk to you more about this.
So, IT at Google, for us,
we think of ourselves
as Google's pit crew.
We're the people who do
the engineering that runs
the business of Google.
And the way that we do that,
our goal in doing this, is to
use exactly the same tools,
like AppEngine, for example,
that you all came to
IO to learn about.
The goal that we have, the
mission for the organization is
to have Google itself as an
enterprise run completely in
the crowd-- in the cloud,
excuse me, you're the
crowd, we're the cloud.
So, let's find out a
little bit about you all.
How many of you have done
anything with AppEngine before?
Written anything, tried it
out, using it right now?
Awesome, awesome, that's great.
That's a lot of hands
for all you on Youtube.
How many of you are curious
about using AppEngine for your
organizations or businesses?
Excellent.
All right, you're in
the right place.
Just as a spot check, how many
of you came here because you
heard we'd be giving out
t-shirts at the end?
All right.
So, it's really us we're
selling, that's good.
That's great.
So what is the what?
Our supposition, which proves
to have been correct, was that
you're here because you want to
understand how you can write
and run applications for
your businesses, for your
organizations, that run on
AppEngine in the Google cloud.
So great, that's what we're
here to tell you about.
As Google's CIO, I feel an
obligation to step back a
little bit and make sure we're
all on the same page about why
this is a good idea and
something that you'd want to do
for your organizations.
So kind of the nightmare side
of every CIO's life is the fact
that the stuff that we do, the
IT that gets valued by our
users, is like the part of the
iceberg that's above the water.
But the reality of it is, in
order to do that stuff that
people can actually see and
touch and experience, we have
to make an enormous effort and
investment in all this
technology that's
below the water line.
This is the stuff that our
end-users never directly
interact with and never
actually kind of-- they
only care about it when
it doesn't work, right?
That stuff only exists to
enable the technology that
makes our organizations
better in some way.
But the problem is, is that-- I
think the stat I heard at the
keynote was, you can spend up
to 60% of your IT spend
actually engaged in just
operating your environment, and
all that is a distraction of
every sort from what you really
should be doing, which is
building technology that
matters to your company, makes
a difference to your company,
and delivering the technology
to the people in your company.
Now, you know, part one of the
problem is, of course, you
have to support hardware.
You need hardware
to do this, right?
That means you need servers and
storage and networks and data
centers and guys in
fuschia-colored shirts who
probably went to Cal Tech to
run all that stuff for you, so
you can have-- so you can
have a place to run
your apps, right?
And this is problem number one.
The hardware environment
that you need to invest in,
in order to run your own
apps, is really expensive.
And ultimately, it's not,
again, what your IT department
is about, and what your IT
department is about is all the
stuff that this stuff enables.
So by way of comparison, let's
talk about what AppEngine
offers that changes
the game here.
So, this is a picture of
a Google data center.
That's Larry Hefley, who is a
Google data center operations
technician, he's been with
the company for some time.
And if a picture actually tells
a thousand words, then we might
have to look into this picture
a little bit to understand
the differences.
Larry's in a Google data
center, and if you'll notice,
look closely, you'll see that
servers that surround him don't
look like the servers that are
probably in your company.
Google-- fundamentally, part
one of the value proposition of
AppEngine and the Google cloud
is that Google presents a
unique economy of scale that we
can share with you,
through AppEngine.
And to give an example of what
that economy of scale is, it's
cost effective for Google
to actually design and
build its own servers.
These are Google servers that
actually have batteries
attached to them for
power purposes.
But we have teams that design
and build servers for us.
That makes sense.
We get great cost efficiencies
out of doing that.
And on top of that, we design
custom data centers to
house these servers, right?
And because of the unique
relationship between the Google
servers and the software that
runs on those Google servers,
and the Google data centers,
we're able to achieve, you
know, industry-leading power
utilization efficiency
numbers for these data
centers as a result.
Finally, on top of that,
because those data centers are
so big, we can put them in
places where we can get the
cheapest possible power.
As a case in point, I mean, it
makes sense for us to go and
find fully-depreciated
hydroelectric dams, places
where we'd want to plop down
one of these massive
data centers.
You know, there's only a
handful of organizations in the
world that are ever going to
have these opportunities
and these kinds of
economies of scale.
And the first element, what's
great about AppEngine, and why
you should all be interested in
it-- or if you're not CIOs, why
your CIOs should be interested
in it-- is that AppEngine
is-- you know, all clouds
are not created equal.
AppEngine is a vehicle for you
to tap into these unique
economies of scale that Google
and very few others have.
But it's not just about the
hardware, and doing hardware
and all the stuff that runs
that hardware cheaper.
The great point of AppEngine
is that it's a platform.
It's a web-run time.
And what that means is, when
you write apps that run on
AppEngine, there's a whole
bunch of platform issues that
you don't have to make an
investment in that you get
for free just by writing
to the AppEngine APIs.
The stuff on this little--
stack of library books is
incredibly important for every
organization to do, to deliver
technology, but these things
themselves don't make an
organization great, right?
These are part of a platform
for applications that make
your organization great.
And what's so cool about
AppEngine is you get all this
stuff for free, you have to
make no conceptual investment
in these sorts of areas of
technology in order to deliver
great applications
to your company.
So, part one of the AppEngine
advantage is unique economies
of scale on the hardware side,
and part two is you're buying
into an entire platform.
And the virtue of that platform
is there's a whole set of
systems activities you don't
have to be concerned with
anymore and you don't have
to dilute your focus from
delivering applications that
make your company better.
So there's a better way, and
it's based on running in the
cloud and running on AppEngine,
but in order to take advantage
of this, you can't just build
applications exactly the way
you were before, right?
It's not easy to make
this transition.
Making a transition-- I think
any organization that wasn't
started today has the problem
that they've got a bunch of
stuff in their data
centers running their
companies already.
Google has exactly these same
problems, we're just like
all of you in that regard.
We've got a bunch of the
same business concerns that
every organization has.
We've got a bunch of corporate
data centers that host
applications that were written
in the age before there
was an AppEngine.
And figuring out how to make
this transition, how to move to
being a cloud-based enterprise,
is hard when so many of your
key assets, whether they be
software or services or
whatever, are still
inside your data center.
So that's-- the transition
is point number one about
what makes this hard.
And point number two about what
makes this hard is that,
although AppEngine is great,
because you're using familiar
tools and languages that we all
know and love, like Python and
Java, you can't write
your applications in
exactly the same way.
Part of the platform
requires you to make
some coding changes.
And this stuff isn't
necessarily obvious, there
aren't a lot of footprints to
be followed for enterprises in
making this transaction.
But we figured it out.
This is part of our
organization's mission, is to
do this and share it with you.
And we're here to
do that right now.
And so with that, I'm going to
introduce the first of the
three development teams, the
first of the three corporate
engineers and development
teams, who're going to talk
about how we did this for some
applications that run the
business of Google today.
First up is Justin who's here
to talk about AppReduce.
00:08:14,878 --> 00:08:14,33
JUSTIN MCWILLIAMS: Thanks, Ben.
Hello
everyone, I'm Justin
McWilliams, one of two
engineers that built AppReduce.
So, by a show of hands, how
many of you have licensed
software on your
corporate workstations?
So, as expected, a lot of you.
And how many of you, at some
point, have realized that you
no longer needed a piece of
licensed software, or maybe
even forgotten that it was
installed in the first place?
Again, a lot of you.
So lastly, how many of your
companies attempt to reclaim
unused software licenses?
I see a couple of
hands here and there.
OK.
So that's exactly what
AppReduce addresses.
And we do this by providing
transparency to our employees
around the software licenses
that are in use by
their computers.
So you can see here, we
provide them with the overall
cost of their computer.
Compare that to the average
Googler, the average Googler in
their department maybe, and
then down below, up-- a quick
list of the software that's
installed on their computer,
associated licensing costs,
and an uninstall button.
So, when this uninstall button
is clicked, we actually make a
call back to a corporate
inventory service that
automatically uninstalls that
application from
their computer.
And I'll go into a little
bit more detail about
how that works later.
So how did we build AppReduce?
Well, initially, we designed
and developed for a traditional
LAMP stack, where we basically
had an Apache server, and when
the user visited the site, we
would directly connect to four
or five databases and APIs on
the fly, pull down all of the
application data, loop over it,
do, you know, regular
expression matching for
licenses, do some cost
calculation, all this stuff on
the fly, and then present
the page to the user.
So we decided to port to
AppEngine for many of the
reasons that Ben mentioned, and
we found that we could use the
same frameworks that we were
familiar with the LAMP stack.
So AppReduce is built with
Django and Python, we used
Google Closure JavaScript
Library for much of our
front-end and UI elements, and
the chart API for various
reports, one of which you saw
on the first slide, and Google
Analytics for usage tracking.
So importing to AppEngine, we
did encounter some challenges,
however, and one of
them is fairly obvious.
How do we get at this data
that's residing in our
corporate network
from AppEngine?
And the answer here is
Secure Data Connector.
So, Secure Data Connector is a
way to create a secure tunnel
from AppEngine, or out in the
cloud-- anywhere in the cloud--
to make HTTP calls back into
your corporate network
to whitelisted URLs.
So a good example of where we
use this, was to access our
Remedy helpdesk ticketing
system API, which
was pre-existing.
So we're able to file tickets
from AppReduce, Googlers could
report inaccurate inventory
data, or ask questions about a
particular license or
open-source alternatives,
things like this.
So you might ask, what
about non-HTTP services?
And the answer is to write an
HTTP wrapper around that
service, and one example of
this was for Microsoft System
Center Configuration Manager,
formerly known as System
Management Server, which is a
corporate inventory system
built by Microsoft.
So we wrote an HTTP wrapper
around this service, so when
users click that uninstall
button that you saw, we would
make an HTTP call through SDC
into our HTTP wrapper, which
would then translate that call
to Windows Management
instrumentation to interface
with SDC or SMS to push out
that uninstaller
to the machine.
So the next challenge was
real-time user performance.
If you remember, back on the
LAMP slide that I showed you, I
mentioned that we were directly
connecting to all of these
databases and APIs on the fly.
And we found that, when moving
to AppEngine, this was
providing for a sub-optimal
user experience due to the fact
that the-- your back ends and
your databases are inside of
your corporate network, and the
AppEngines front ends may be,
you know, somewhere else
out in the internet, so
there's added latency.
So to get around this, we
actually ended up caching a lot
of our corporate data in the
cloud, using Bulkloader.
So we have code that runs in
our corporate network that
fetches this same data on a
regular basis, does all of the
aggregation and the cost
calculation and license
matching up front, and
then hands it off over to
Bulkloader to shovel up into
AppEngine's data store.
So we're actually using this to
push about 75,000 rows of data,
three times per day, and it's
been really great for us.
Bulkloader handles, like,
automatic error retrying, it
handles throttling, threading,
it's really just a-- it's a
great way to get data from
your corporate network
up into the cloud.
So here's an overall
design of AppReduce.
And a lot of this should be
familiar, you'll see the
corporate network on the
right-hand side with all of
your inventory systems and
services, and AppEngine and
AppReduce on the
left-hand side.
Secure Data Connector and
Bulkloader bridging the gap
between the two of those, and
again, as mentioned, when the
user visits the AppReduce front
end, all of this data is going
to be loaded from the local
data store, and we even have a
memcache layer in between there
to reduce redundant hits
on the data store.
The new piece here is the
section up top, the GAE
Cron and Task Queue.
So task queues are a way to run
code in the background in
AppEngine, sort of independent
from the user's interaction
with the site, and we use this
for various-- various reasons.
But I'll give you a
couple of examples.
So, first off, status E-mails.
We send Googlers E-mails on a
regular basis, reminding them
of AppReduce, reminding them of
the licenses they have on their
machine, and asking them to
come uninstall applications
that they no longer need.
Another example is
uninstallation verification.
So, on a regular basis, we're
checking to make sure that,
when that uninstall button is
clicked, those applications are
actually being uninstalled by
the inventory systems, and if
not, then we can, you know,
raise flags and E-mail the
administrators of those systems
so they can have a look and
see why it's not working.
So, all in all, we found that
putting information into
Googler's hands can be very
powerful, and transparency at
Google is well-received
in general.
To date, we've saved over
$450,000 by recycling licenses,
and within twenty-four hours of
launch, we actually had over a
$150,000 worth of savings.
Which, by the way, we had QPS
spikes up to fifty, and it's
the same twenty QPS for
several hours after launch.
We totally did not expect
adoption like this up front,
due to the corporate nature of
this application, but AppEngine
handled it quite well
for us, so that was
a pleasant surprise.
So it's also worth mentioning
that AppReduce was built,
released, and supported
by only two engineers,
myself and one other.
And I think this is a good
testament of what it takes to
build something like this
in the cloud, on AppEngine.
You don't really need a team
of ten or twenty people.
And lastly, about two weeks
after we launched AppReduce,
myself and the other engineer
were actually allocated on
other projects, and AppReduce
kept on chugging
along by itself.
We didn't really have
to worry about it.
The AppEngine platform took
care of things like server
uptime and monitoring and all
those sorts of things that a
normal developer would have
to handle themselves.
So I think this is a-- this is
our experience with building an
application in the cloud that
requires corporate inventory
systems and data that's behind
your corporate network, and
this is a theme that I
think you'll see in
the next presentation.
Please welcome Matthew
Simmons with the
TechStop Online Project.
00:16:16,28 --> 00:16:16,058
MATTHEW SIMMONS:
Thank you, Justin.
Thank you all for being here.
Welcome.
As Justin said, my name
is Matthew Simmons.
The project I work on is
TechStop Online, I'm one of the
developers that work on that.
So, what is TechStop Online?
Well, TechStop Online is where
we keep all of our internal IT
support documentation that we
use to support our users.
Its namesake actually tells
you a little bit about
what TechStop Online is.
Techstops are rooms in each
Google office where you can
go to get fast, friendly,
efficient IT support.
We aim to be the online
equivalent of that.
In
essence, you can think of
it like a CMS, or content
management system.
We provide a lot of the same
features, and we have a lot
of the same requirements.
Previously, we were deployed in
a managed LAMP environment,
using an OSS/CMS solution, and
we migrated to AppEngine for a
variety of reasons, many of
which Ben covered, and some of
which I will cover in a second.
Like AppReduce, we deployed
using the Django framework on
AppEngine, and the Google
Closure JavaScript Library.
We make use of a lot of the
same technologies: Secure
Tata Connector, Task
Queue, Bulkloader.
So I mentioned that we
had some motivations for
moving on to AppEngine.
Primarily I'm going to cover
scalability, which was one of
the places where we saw
the greatest benefit.
I'm also going to cover some of
the challenges we encountered
moving to AppEngine, some of
the shifts in development
paradigm that we had to
accommodate and I'm going to
close out with a couple of tips
that we found to be useful.
So, I mentioned scalability,
I kind of think of
it as bursty demand.
This is-- these graphs
are going to look pretty
familiar to anyone who
runs web applications.
On one side, you're going to
have your normal periodic
demand on your application.
For us as a support
documentation thing, this is
your weekly demand spiked with
weekdays high, weekends low,
and represents things
like users saying aah!
Coffee plus keyboard
equals bad!
Tell me how to get
a new keyboard!
And on the other side, you
have A sudden surge in
demand for a single thing.
Again, that's going to
vary by what application
we're talking about.
For us, it could be we change
our remote access policy, and
the night before everyone needs
to get the documentation to
see how to install the new
remote access software.
That's when the documentation
system is the most valuable.
It's when it's under
the most load.
It's also when it's the most
brittle, traditionally.
It's the most likely to break.
Which is bad, because everyone
needs the same information, and
the fallback are the people
sitting in the tech stops, and
they don't parallelize as
well as documentation does.
So, we did handle scalability
when we were deployed in
a different environment.
The challenge we faced was it
took a lot of our attention.
We had to develop-- devote a
lot of cycles to dealing with
these scalability concerns.
We were kind of having to
allocate development cycles to
platform concerns, instead of
develop-- devoting them to
actually making the
application better.
Things that we wanted to
deliver on for our users.
So, when we moved to AppEngine,
we were really pleasantly
surprised to find that we
stopped having to really devote
a lot of thought to how we
make sure our app scales.
We freed up a lot of cycles.
It allowed us to address a lot
of these application-level
concerns that we
wanted to address.
What were some of those?
Well, our philosophy is that
you can have the best,
most accurate support
documentation in the world.
It can be the most appropriate
for the problem at hand, but if
the user can't find
it, it's worthless.
So, navigation, specifically
in this case search, was
one of the first things
that we looked at.
So, what we found was that,
because we implemented our
article content with AppEngine
text properties, and at the
time they weren't indexed, we
didn't have a quick convenient
way to search within the
article content and return
a specific article within
the AppEngine framework.
This is a problem that we
decided that we needed
to tackle ourselves.
We had a couple of approaches.
The first approach was we
decided to try and do
information retrieval
ourselves.
We stripped the HTML, we
tokenized it, we built indexes,
we did all that jazz, and we
did all it in AppEngine,
and it worked.
But then we got to thinking.
You know, we're spending
a lot of time trying to
implement search here.
Maybe, at a big company like
this, someone has tackled
the search problem before.
Maybe we can work off of
someone else's work.
Well, it turns out, someone at
Google has thought about search
before, and we were able to use
the Google Search Appliance
that sits in our corporate
network to index our help
support documentation.
We again encountered a
challenge, that challenge
being that our documentation
repository was now in the
cloud, and our Google search
appliance was on our
corporate network, and a
firewall lay betwixt.
This is where we used the SDC,
and you heard Justin talk a
little bit about the SDC
earlier, the Secure
Data Connector.
We found it to be a great way
to communicate and to leverage
these resources that we already
had in our corporate
environment, and sort of get a
lot of efficiency out of things
that we-- work that had
already been done.
Additionally, SDC is really
easy to use, or we found
it really easy to use.
This is an example call to SDC.
If you take away the
highlighted part, it looks
just like a URL fetch.
The resource in question
happens to be behind the
corporate firewall and would
otherwise be denied, but by
adding this header's use
intranet yes, you've turned
it into an SDC call.
Really, we found it to be
a fantastic solution.
The next thing we went after
was, again, along the
navigation theme, was tackling
what happened if a user didn't
get the perfect document on the
first hit of their search
results, or if they clicked on
a search result and it
wasn't the right one.
We wanted to provide them a
link to what they were really
looking for on the page, so we
wanted a recommendation system.
We decided to implement it
using similarity calculations,
and that's kind of
all beside the point.
The point is that all of
those calculations took a
really long time to run.
And every time you add a new
article in a CMS, you would
have to rebuild this
similarity index.
So this is a very
long running task.
It would almost always run
longer than the thirty second
request response cycle allowed.
What we found is we could use
the Task Queue, the AppEngine
Task Queue functionality,
to not only-- oh!
00:23:31,8 --> 00:23:31,584
Technological failure!
There we go-- not only get the
job done, because we could
split it up and defer it and
run these task-- these
similarity calculations
asynchronously, which is what
Task Queue does fantastically,
but it also got it out
of the way of the user.
Right?
So an article author finishes,
they submit their article, and
we have to figure out the
similarity, but they don't
need to wait what happens.
So, Task Queue's ability to
make-- to get the task out-- or
the technology out of the way
of the task, we really
enjoyed as well.
Now, when I think about
database design, my first
reaction is to think in terms
of relational database systems.
So I start thinking about
normalization, I start thinking
about, you know, which
normal form, et cetera.
This was a shift for us.
AppEngine works really well a
de-normalized data schema.
So, we eventually came around
to not thinking about
normalization as much, and it
worked out really well for us.
That's not saying that
you can't have links
between entities.
00:24:34,64 --> 00:24:34,58
You can.
You can use the AppEngine
reference property.
One of the things that we
encountered while using the
reference property is that
every time you access an
attribute that's a reference
property, it'll fire an RPC
to data store to pull the
reference down to the end.
If you're iterating over
something, a set of entities
that have reference properties,
and you want to access
something on the referenced
entity, you're going to be
throwing an RPC to retrieve
that in every part of the loop.
That can lead to some issues.
What we found is it's really
efficient to figure out what
you're going to want and to
cache it, to take that piece of
data and programmatically cache
it on the entity you're
iterating over.
That, for our application,
solved some of the problems
that we were having, and
it's a very good thing
to keep in mind.
Another thing that we found,
another advantage of developing
on AppEngine is, as a small
team-- and we are a fairly
small team-- maintaining
a test instance was a
significant of work.
More work than we
wanted it to be.
We had to spin up a separate
environment and then we had to
keep it roughly representative
of the production environment.
So when we were testing new
changes, we were actually
testing it against something
that represented the
real environment.
With AppEngine, one of the
approaches that we found to
be useful was to register a
second application with a
slightly different name.
In our case, we would append
-QA, Quality Assurance
instance, and you could
use anything, really.
But the idea is that you would
push out, when you pushed your
production instance, to this
other instance that you have
registered at the same time,
and now you have the same code
base on two AppEngine apps,
and you have sort of a
baked-in test environment.
On top of that, we had multiple
people on the team that were
testing multiple different
functionalities.
We found that the version
string for each app was a great
way to give each developer
their own little sandbox to
test their own feature changes.
So in summary, we found
AppEngine for TSOL, or
TechStop Online to be
scalable by default.
The ability to fetch
corporate data with the
SDC was a great boon.
Deferring expensive jobs to the
task queue was essential in
making TechStop Online work
the way we wanted it to.
And then, learning about data
storage normalization and
setting up a test instance
really helped us sort of
iterate away and create
great applications.
And with that, I'm going
to hand it over to Irwin.
IRWIN BOUTBOUL: Thanks, Matt.
Hi.
My name is Irwin, and I'm
one of the two engineers
who built CloudCourse.
During this presentation, which
is going to be a bit more
technical, we'll go quickly
over what CloudCourse is, then
we'll look at the challenges we
faced building this application
and how we addressed
those challenges.
So what is CloudCourse?
CloudCourse is a course
scheduling system, so basically
it's a platform which allows
people who want to teach a
particular course to reach out
to people who want
to learn about it.
Say, for example, I want to
teach a Python 101 class.
I would go into the system,
create a new activity Python
101, and then I would
schedule some sessions.
I'm going to teach it in New
York City on Monday, in
Mountain View on Friday,
and over webcast also.
I'm going to add some
constraints to this.
I don't want more than ten
people to sign up for my class.
At some point later, someone
would go into the system
and make a search.
Say, all right, I want to learn
about Python, tell me what you
have next month in
San Francisco.
And then we're going to return
a list of sessions available.
Some of them are going to be
open, people can sign up, some
of them are going to be full
and the user is going
to be wait-listed.
That's in a nutshell
what CloudCourse is.
A course scheduling system.
How do you do it?
One, surprise surprise,
AppEngine and Python.
For the front end, we'll use
the Django web framework and
the Closure JavaScript Library.
And we use GData to do calendar
updates, so when a user signs
up on CloudCourse, we
automatically update
their calendars.
All right, now the fun part.
Our challenges.
An application like CloudCourse
is inherently very relational.
How do we deal with the fact
that we don't have joins?
Second one.
Long-running computation.
There's a lot of things
we have to do which are
going to take some time.
Say, for example, you
have a session with ten
people enrolled and ten
people wait-listed.
Someone is going to drop out
from that particular class.
We have to reprocess the
wait-listed people, and when
doing so, we need to send
E-mails, we need to update
calendars, get user
permissions, and whatnot.
And this takes time.
How do we deal with these
long-running computation?
And finally, we'll go into
details on how we managed to
build a high-performance
transactional system, and we'll
look at what we mean exactly.
So let's start with
the first one.
No joins.
This is how a course scheduling
system would look in a
relational database.
Your regular sequel stack.
You have an activity table
and a session table.
It's a one-to-many relationship
between the activity
and the sessions.
Now, when a user goes into the
system and says, all right,
give me all the Python sessions
you have available in June in
San Francisco, we need to do
a join between the activity
table and the session table.
And this is because of this
name on the activity.
Now, we don't have joins.
So how do you deal when
you don't have joins?
Well, what about we merge
everything in one table so
there's nothing to join
on, you have one table?
We can do this.
We have the name of the
activity, the sessions we're
going to serialize them in the
list as binary blobs, and then
we look at the query
we need to do.
The query is about finding the
sessions of interest for a
particular date and location.
So we need to be able to
index on those pairs
of date and location.
One easy way to do this is to
put those pairs in the list.
And this list is going
to be automatically
indexed by data store.
So now, when I run a query,
I'm going to be able to do an
index lookup on this table.
That works, but that comes
with some limitations.
If you take this
simple approach.
One is exploding indices.
You cannot have more than 1,300
indices in data store, so
depending on how many pairs of
data and location you have,
this approach may not work.
The second issue is one
megabyte limits on every entity
you store in data store.
If you have a lot of sessions,
that could be fine, but now, if
you put a lot of data on each
session, you may run
into these limits.
And last but not least,
you a performance issue
with this approach.
It's not good, because now,
every time you want to look up
a particular session, you're
going to have to fetch this
whole activity into memory to
extract the session
of interest.
So even though, when you do
an index look-up it find
this activity, you are
only interested in a
particular session.
And you're going to have to
load this into memory and to
process it, and it's a
performance issue, and
eventually it's going to impact
your quota, which is not good.
So how do we address this?
Well, we look at the query.
Why do we join in
the first place?
We join in the first place
because of this named property.
So we're going to de-normalize
this, and we're going to
replicate the named property
at the session level.
By doing this, we don't have
any exploding indices issue,
because we don't have a
list we have to index.
We don't have the one megabyte
limit, because now we can do an
index look-up on the particular
session of interest.
This session contains all the
information we can index, which
is date, location, and name.
And finally, no performance
issue because we look
up only one session.
Now, I can see some eyebrows
raising, and what is it?
Like, we just de-normalize
data and that's it?
It's going to work?
No, it comes with trade-offs.
And it's not trivial.
Imagine you have one activity
with a thousand sessions.
Now, you need to take care of
the relational integrity at the
application level, because your
back end is not going
to do it for you.
This is not straightforward.
How do you update this name on
a thousand or ten thousand
entities at the same time?
It's a long-running process,
and this leads us to
our second challenge.
Which is long-running
computation.
Let's start by describing what
do we put in this long-running
computation problem?
Well, definitely, everything
which doesn't fit thirty
seconds on AppEngine will
fall into that category.
But we want to put
more than this.
Everything which is going to
impact the user experience--
500 miliseconds, one second,
two seconds-- we're going to
consider this as long-running
computation and we don't want
the user to see this
happening when they interact
with our web sites.
So we're going to push the
burden of the work to back
end processes, like
calendar updates.
That's a call to
an external API.
When you do this in your
enterprise, maybe you want to
modify Microsoft Outlook.
Maybe it's going to
take two seconds.
You want to push this
in the back end.
How do we push this?
We use tasks, but we use a
special attribute which is a
transactional option when
you un-queue a task.
Say someone signs up on the web
site for a class, Python 101.
We have to update the calendar,
but we want to update the
calendar if and only if we're
100% sure that the transaction
that the user is doing is
going to commit property.
So the way we do this is we
start the transaction, then we
un-queue a task with this
transactional flag, and only
when the transaction commits
will this task be deferred
in the background.
And to do this, there's a very
nice API in Python that is not
very well advertised, and
it's called Deferred API.
Basically, you can defer any
method call without having to
write a specific
handler for it.
So as a developer, this
is very convenient.
So now you can have all
these tasks running in the
background, and they may
contend and race for
the same resources.
That is going to, maybe slow
the throughput of your system,
because you're going to have
contention between
all those tasks.
So one thing which is very
useful is to chain those tasks.
And to chain tasks, you can
leverage call jobs very easily.
Let's look at our
last challenge.
High performance
transactional work flows.
Take an example, Google IO.
We have a limit, 5,000
seats available.
We send a notification
to millions of people
at the same time.
Now, at any given time, dozens
of people are going to try
to register for Google
IO at the same time.
How do we make sure that we
have this limit of 5,000, and
every time someone signs up,
we're going to be able
to say yes or no?
The way to do this is by
having a transaction
on this information.
On AppEngine, the way you
do this is by leveraging
entity groups.
It's basically the way to group
entities so that you can
leverage a transaction when
you work on those entities.
In our sample, we have the
activity as a session and the
fact that the user is signing
up for a particular session
in the same entity group.
So when the user goes on the
web site and signs up, we stop
the transaction on this group,
we look up how many users do we
have right now, and then we can
give you an answer yes, you are
below the limit, you are going
to be enrolled, or you're
going to be wait-listed.
Now, this is a natural
approach on AppEngine.
But now, every sign up
becomes a transaction on
the particular entity.
And you cannot get a lot of
transactions on the same
entity at any given time.
Basically, you're going to get
one to ten, depending on what
your application does, and one
to ten is just too slow for us.
Think about it like, twelve
users come at the same time,
try to sign up, some of them
are going to get timed out,
so a ten-second delay.
That's not an acceptable
user experience.
How do we improve this?
Well, why do we have this
bottleneck to start with?
That's because we add the
enrollments in the same
entity group as the
activity and the session.
The enrollment is where we have
thousands of users contending
for the same resources.
So we're going to
break this apart.
And we're going to take
the enrollments out
of the entity group.
Now, if you're still following,
the reason to be concerned now.
How do we make sure that we
have these transactional
semantics, now that we
removed the enrollment
from this entity group?
Well, the way we work around
this is by constructing our
application in a certain way so
that we're going to leverage a
memcache API that some
of you may know.
It's called Increment and
Decrement, and what's
interesting about this
particular API is that it
has atomic semantics.
So at any given time, there's
only going to be one process
which can access this.
So how do we use this?
Well, we have a counter in
memcache which is going to keep
track of how many people do I
have signed up for that
particular course
at any given time.
Every time someone signs up,
I increment this counter.
And I can check, if it's below
the limit it's OK, if it's
above the limit I'm going
to wait-list the user.
Now, this is a cache, and like
every other cache, whatever
you put inside it can be
evicted at any given time.
And when your counter drops
out from this cache,
you need to rebuild it.
And this is where things
get interesting.
How do you rebuild this cache?
Well, if you want to be exact,
you need to build this-- you
need to take this big giant log
on the activities of session
and the user enrollment
information to be able to count
the exact number of people who
have signed up at that
particular moment of time, and
you need to have this log
because you don't want someone
else to sign up while you're
counting how many people
have signed up so far.
But if we take this giant log,
we're back to square one.
We have these limits of one
to ten per seconds, and we
don't want these limits.
So the way we're going to
construct this counter is
by being conservative.
When we count the number of
people who are enrolled at
any given time, we don't
want the exact count.
Really, what we want is
a conservative count.
And the way we construct these
counts, now when someone signs
up, we're going to
say, all right.
You have a session with ten
people enrolled and your limit
is ten for this session.
And we're going to have
to wait-list two berths.
It could be that we think this
counter is ten, even though
there's really nine people
enrolled at that time, because
when we construct it,
we're conservative.
So in most cases, the user
experience online is
going to be good.
We're going to be able to give
approximately a good response
for the counter, and then the
people are going
to be enrolled.
In those very edge cases,
some people are going to
be wait-listed even though
really they could have been
enrolled, but that's OK.
Because we have a back end
process which, offline, is
going to correct those answers.
It's going to do an exact count
by taking this big giant log on
everything, the activities, the
session, and the users, and it
will either confirm or deny the
response that the
user got online.
And this back end process can
proceed at its own pace, one to
ten per second, that's fine.
What we care about is the user
experience online, which
is going to be good.
So what does this user
experience look like in
terms of performance?
This is a profiling of a user
signing up for a class online.
There's about fifteen RPC calls
here, but the one which is of
interest is the memcache API:.
The memcache increment is
taking eight milliseconds.
And that's a conservative
approach, but let's say-- all
right, eight, ten milliseconds.
That's, if you do the math,
about a hundred plus rights
per second, hundred plus
signed up for an activity.
Hundred plus signed up
for one single activity,
like Google IO.
But you're on AppEngine, right?
You don't have only
one activity.
You may have ten, hundred,
thousand, billions.
The underlying data
store supports it.
So, think about it.
A thousand classes, a thousand
courses, hundred plus signed up
per second for each one of
them, that's a 100,000 signed
up per second in the
transactional workflow.
Now, let's take a step back
and see what we just did.
We took a schema, relational
schema, the one you're very
familiar with, we analyzed
the type of queries that our
system does, and we made
a small de-normalization.
Not too complex.
And then we leverage an
existing API, which has atomic
semantics, and we come up with
a system which supports 100,000
plus transactions per second.
Now,
that's pretty good.
As an application developer, I
don't have to care about tuning
my JVM, how much memory do I
have, what's my fail-over
policy, how do I deal
with all those things.
Usually you spend months
working on those things.
I didn't have to tune
the application.
And I get that kind
of scalability.
Even if that doesn't make you
feel good, it's going to make
feel good your CIO, because
you don't have to provision
any missions here.
This application runs
when it needs to run.
And yesterday I took a look at
our internal deployment of
CloudCourse, and we have
20,00 employees in Google.
We have about 1,000 signs-up
every day on classes on this
system, and we are still
running below the free quarter.
So take an application like
this, deploy it on your-- in
your organization, and
it comes for free.
No maintenance, no
strings attached.
So let's see what
we just went over.
De-normalization trade-offs:
again, don't be afraid of
de-normalization, don't
de-normalize everything, you
have to look at the type of
queries that you make, and
maybe you're not going to
have to de-normalize
any of your data.
Asynchronous processing: we
went over this with AppReduce,
TechStop Online, CloudCourse.
You want to defer in the
background as much as possible
when deploying on AppEngine.
And finally, we've seen how we
can leverage some advanced APIs
to build a high-performance
transactional system.
And with that side I'm going
to turn it over to Ben with
some interesting news.
00:43:45,558 --> 00:43:45,53
BEN FRIED:
All right.
Thanks, Irwin.
So, speaking of CloudCourse, we
have an announcement to make,
which is that CloudCourse is
available as open source
for you all today.
There's the URL on the screen,
you can download it, install
it in AppEngine, run it for
your organization right now.
It's exactly the same code that
we're running inside Google,
available to you today.
There's going to be a posting
on the Google Opensource blog
about this, theoretically in
about nine minutes, so we can
share this with the world.
And, as Irwin said, even a
company the size of Google can
run this with really, really
little impact on
the bottom line.
If you're not a CIO, go back
and tell your CIO, they might
be kind of happy to
hear about this.
Now, it is our intent, is our
aspiration to follow exactly
the same open sourcing policy
with TechStop Online and
AppReduce, but the reality of
it is that we're not as far
down the path with those two
apps as we are with this one.
In the case of AppReduce, we
have the source code and the
design documents for the demon
that sits in front of SMS or
SCCM are available right now,
and we've got some general-- oh
sorry, for TechStop Online, we
have that, and we have-- I was
right, AppReduce the first
time, coffee gave out on me.
And then some design docs we
have produced are available as
well, and hopefully we'll have
some announcements about
TechStop Online coming soon.
Finally, you know, we've got
the engineers who built these
apps are in the AppEngine
sandbox, and they're-- be more
than happy to demo these or
other applications that we use
to run Google on Google's
cloud technologies
for all of you today.
Or tomorrow.
So please, stop by, get a demo,
ask us questions if there's
something you want to
ask us one-on-one.
And now I think we'll cut over
to Q&A, let's flip over to
the moderator, and we do have
t-shirts that we're giving out.
If you want to ask a question
live, you can definitely
get a t-shirt.
Let's get the t-shirt
artillery team ready.
MODERATOR: One thing.
Please, if you can, make use of
the microphones in the aisles
so that we'll be able to
capture your questions
for posterity.
BEN FRIED: So, I should add
that we have a bunch of our
friends from the AppEngine team
are here to help answer
questions, since we anticipated
a bunch of questions.
It might be more AppEngine or
SDC-ish than just about what
we do here at Google,
so here we are.
All right.
T-shirt number one.
00:46:04,958 --> 00:46:04,148
OK.
How many of the Google teams
have a t-shirt slingshot?
OK?
All right, so the first
question-- you all signed a
release when you joined.
OK.
Running a 250GB database for a
well-known association, think
minty chocolate cookies, not
sure we could entirely get away
from our sequel back end.
Do you foresee any ability
to replicate in and out
of AppEngine with such
a large database?
Sean.
SEAN LYNCH: I guess
I'll take this one.
So there's a couple
of issues on--
BEN FRIED: Did you
introduce yourself, Sean?
00:46:34,96 --> 00:46:34,73
SEAN LYNCH: Oh yeah.
Sorry.
I'm Sean Lynch, I'm the
AppEngine product manager.
So there's a couple of issues
sort of woven into the
same question here.
In terms of size of database,
250GB is fine on data
stores that exist today.
We have customers that are
using databases substantially
larger than that.
The sequel piece, as you saw in
today's keynote, is something
that we're excited to announce
and that's coming, so you will
be able to do-- it wasn't sort
of mentioned in today's talks
because they're not using it
either yet, but that's
something that we hope that
people will have available to
them in the near future.
The replicated part, that's a
little bit more interesting, I
think it's one that we have to
talk about, especially if
there's a lot of interest in
that, but at the moment I don't
think that's a specific
on the road map.
BEN FRIED: OK, so let's go to a
live question here in the room.
SEAN LYNCH: There is, as a
pitch for one of the other tech
talks we have later today.
There is the Bulkloader API,
and we have a new version of
that we released this morning.
So we'll be going over that
in a later session as well.
Matt Blaine's actually going to
be teaching that one what can
be used to accomplish that.
BEN FRIED: OK, so live
questions in the room.
Sir.
00:47:50,378 --> 00:47:50,138
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Hi.
I don't know much about the
Secure Data Connector.
I was wondering if you
could give a little more
background on that.
Does that run over HTTPS
as like, a transport?
And also, is the CloudCourse
actually using Secure
Data Connector?
IRWIN BOUTBOUL: So I
start with CloudCourse.
CloudCourse internally is using
the Secure Data Connector to
perform services like search.
We also synchronize CloudCourse
data with some other
internal databases.
To do this, yes, internally
we do use CloudCourse.
And in CloudCOurse, you see on
the open source blog, basically
we-- you can plug your own
implementation of different
services like the search
database, the user information
services, to use in your own
enterprise and you can
plug it with SDC.
AUDIENCE: Great, thank you.
DAVE PRIMER: So, I'll
quickly explain.
The base--
00:48:44,198 --> 00:48:44,078
BEN FRIED: Introduce
yourself, my friend.
DAVE PRIMER: Oh, sorry.
I'm Dave Primer, I was
an engineer on Secure
Data Connector.
Secure Data Connector is
basically a technology that
allows Google to reach inside
of your firewall, and it does
that by providing an agent that
you run in your network, and
that agent connects back to
Google and creates a tunnel.
You don't have to actually open
up any ports on your firewall
because the initial connection
is outbound by the agent, and
Google can then use that tunnel
that's been created to make
requests, and the requests
actually originate as if they
were on your internal network.
They use the DNS of the
machine that runs the
agent, and it's-- yeah.
It runs over HTTP and HTTPS.
BEN FRIED: Watch out
for the friendly fire.
All right, so another live
question and then we'll
hit the question on the
moderator after that.
Sir.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
We have about 850GB of files
that we store as just files
in a file system right now.
Would there be any facility
within AppEngine to store
things like that, that are
books, just binary data in that
quantity, or would we use the
Secure Data Connector and host
it on our own network, or?
SEAN LYNCH: So one of the
recent additions to the
AppEngine platform was the Blob
Story PI, and it's more
designed for hosting things
that are, you know, just
arbitrary chunks of data, like
books or, you know, anything
that is bigger than the 1MB
limit so you don't have to
shard it, things like that.
AUDIENCE: What kind of size
limits exist for that?
SEAN LYNCH: So it was 50MB when
we originally launched it,
today we raised it up to 2GB.
So--
AUDIENCE: Total for
the whole index?
SEAN LYNCH: Oh no,
that's per file is 2GB.
00:50:21,32 --> 00:50:21,058
AUDIENCE: Oh, excellent.
Thank you.
BEN FRIED: OK, for those of you
who got t-shirts, by the way, I
should mention that if it's not
your size, come find Tim in the
corner afterwards and
he'll swap out for one
that is your size.
Now, let's go to a question
that appeared on the moderator.
I think this is another
one for Sean, actually.
How does AppEngine address
government data concerns,
specifically HIPAA compliance
and ownership concerns where
data is stored in the cloud and
not on government servers?
GOOGLE ENGINEER: Sure, Ed.
I'll go ahead and
take this one.
You know, it's a
tough question.
There are a lot of different
certifications, and some of
the certifications are
really stringent ones.
For AppEngine, for the
AppEngine product as it is
today and for the AppEngine
business product, we are
pursuing getting these
certifications for
our data centers.
They take a long time to get,
we are working on them, so I
think the best that I can tell
you right now is we not only
know about it, but we are
working on it and we're trying
to get that certification
so you can have that
level of confidence.
Or if it's something that's
required by your employer,
do something for it.
The other thing I can also tell
you is there is a published
document that we have, between
Google AppEngine and Google
Apps, which tells you about
some of the security policies
and how we run our data centers
and how we protect data.
I think it's a great sort of--
I think it's four or five pages
long, but it goes into depth on
just how we run our data
centers, how we control who has
access to what, and all the
procedures that we do.
So I think that's a great thing
to read, or a great thing to
pass on to other people you
might work if they have
concerns about Google.
BEN FRIED: OK, great.
So I'll just take
another live question.
AUDIENCE: I couldn't help
notice that your examples
all use the Python
flavor of the AppEngine.
Are you guys sending a
secret message to us
to deploy Java apps?
BEN FRIED: Oh, no.
00:52:02,988 --> 00:52:02,112
No.
Oh, great question.
Absolutely not.
So, it just so happens that the
goal of the presentation was
for us to show you all problems
that we thought related as
closely as possible to problems
you might have as you thought
about trying to get your
feet wet in AppEngine.
And a lot of that has to
do with how you talk back
to services that are
inside your company.
It just so happens that the
apps that we selected, that we
thought were great exemplars
of solving that kind of
problem, were in Python.
But in fact, I mean, we have an
application that we use for
doing feedback on interview
candidates called Hire/NoHire,
which is a Java GWT AppEngine
app that talks back to our--
inside to our applicant
tracking system, and Matt,
who's the author of that, is
here today and he'll be in the
sandbox if you want to talk
about our experience with
the Java GWT AppEngine
environment as well.
They're both great.
I mean, I think it really has
to do with the skills that you
have and want to have in
your environment, right?
They're-- you know,
we're big fans of both.
Another live question?
AUDIENCE: First there was
Python and then, I guess, Java.
Are there any plans
for future languages?
BEN FRIED: I know of no plan
for a COBOL AppEngine, but--
SEAN LYNCH: So at the moment,
there's nothing official
that we can say.
If there's other languages that
you're looking for, definitely
take a look at some of the
open-source projects out there
to get other languages
running on the JVM.
I know that we have some JRuby
guys here today that have been
really successful, these guys
are-- Closure is actually
in our sandbox, I believe.
So there's a lot of people
doing a lot of really cool
things with other languages
just on top of the JVM.
BEN FRIED: Why don't we take
another live question.
Sir.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
One of things that's talked
about is, it just works.
So, people who deploy their
applications typically monitor
them, IT managers need to
monitor their equipment,
network storage applications.
How do you monitor that within
Google for yourself, so that
you don't get the call
that says it's down and
nobody else fixed it?
And what do you provide to
people who use AppEngine, to
make that possible for them,
or some parts of them?
BEN FRIED: So, one thing, and
this has to do with the
question that's up on the
moderator as well that we
should make clear, is that we
try very hard not to kind of go
around the back door and take
advantage of the fact that
we're all in the same company,
but when it comes to how Google
runs itself, we want to treat
ourselves like a customer.
Obviously the people who work
on AppEngine and the people who
work on these apps are
colleagues and have collegial
relationships and so on, but
it's really important to me for
my organization, and to Kevin
and David and Vic, that we
treat this as a model
provider-customer
relationship, right?
And that we learn about--
AppEngine for Business is
brand-new, we just launched it
today, the goal is that we do
this so we learn about how
to make these business
offering better, right?
If we just kind of went behind
the door and took advantage
of stuff that was only
available to us, we'd be
in real trouble, right?
Because we wouldn't be doing
anything to make these
offerings better.
So, I don't know if that
answers your question, if the
question was specifically
about, hey, we use the
Google dashboard, right?
So, you know, and we can talk
more about the services that
are coming online in AppEngine
Business that'll support you
and all, but we try very hard
to do exactly the same sort of
things that you all
will do as well.
You know, it's because the
products are evolving, how
we do that evolves too, but
the goal is not to cheat.
Are we about to get the boot?
But the clock is
going up, not down.
I thought that meant--
OK, all right.
So we'll be in the sandbox, if
you've got questions, I think
we are getting the yank, so
please come by, ask us
questions, and thank you all.